in a country where anti-government
demonstrations aren't usually tolerated
especially without police clearance
doctors in Zimbabwe demand to know where
Peter mango bay is they blocked some
roads in the capital demanding the
release of the union leader and head of
the hospital doctors Association right
police surround them some senior doctors
tried to negotiate with police so
colleagues could march to the office of
president emerson Managua the answer
from police was no only a few leaders
were allowed to present a petition to
the government 25-year old dr. Mangrum
Bay has been missing since Saturday and
we are seriously concerned about his
welfare
we therefore demand his unconditional
return to his family in the meantime we
have withdrawn our services doctors have
long complained about they pay as well
as the poor state of public hospitals
they are in the same position as most
Suburbans struggling to survive soaring
inflation and shortages of food and
other essentials in recent weeks
government critics opposition supporters
and the teachers union leader allege
they were taken from their homes and
tortured by state security agents some
of ended up in hospital beaten
government officials deny the
allegations police say they are
investigating some in the rulings on
appeal party so the alleged abductions
could be staged to tarnish the country's
image there's been these abductions
unfortunately whenever they are major
events you know with the subject some
time ago then this the South African
issue now we hear these the reporter for
I think Human Rights was coming to
Zimbabwe there's the United Nations in
new coming very soon and in a way one
would think there may be a fed force
trying to
to give Zimbabwe bad name doctors and
nurses strike over pay and working
conditions every few months but hey it's
been a while since one of their owners
gone missing for now the earth look is
defiant vowed not to return to work
until they colleague is found her
Matassa al jazeera Hourani